>>> DESPITE THE LEGAL PUSHBACK,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAYS IT
STILL WANTS TO END TITLE 42 AT
THE U.S. BORDER.
THAT'S A TRUMP ERA PANDEMIC RULE
THAT ALLOWS AUTHORITIES TO CITE
PUBLIC HEALTH TO QUICKLY EJECT
MIGRANTS TRYING TO ENTER THE
COUNTRY.
IF THE RULE IS LIFTED THIS
MONTH, DHS OFFICIALS BELIEVE THE
NUMBER OF MIGRANTS APPREHENDED
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER COULD
CLIMB AS HIGH AS 18,000 PER DAY.
THAT'S TRIPLE THE AMOUNT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY SEEING.
HOMELAND SECURITY CHIEF
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS SAYS THE U.S.
IS READY TO HANDLE THAT SURGE.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT IF,
IN FACT, WE REACH THAT NUMBER
THAT IS GOING TO BE AN
EXTRAORDINARY STRAIN ON OUR
SYSTEM.
BUT WE ARE PREPARING FOR IT, AND
THAT IS WHY THE PLAN WE HAVE
PREPARED CALLS FOR A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ACTIONS, NOT JUST IN
THE DOMESTIC ARENA, BUT ALSO
WITH OUR PARTNERS TO THE SOUTH.
>> JOINING US NOW IS DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN PRAMILA JAYAPAL,
CONGRESSWOMAN, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
LET'S START THERE WITH TITLE 42.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE READY TO END
THAT, BUT MANY OF YOUR EVEN
FELLOW DEMOCRATS SAY IT IS TOO
SOON.
I'LL JUST GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE.
THIS COMES FROM CONGRESSMAN TIM
RYAN OF OHIO.
HE SAYS QUOTE PREMATURELY ENDING
THIS POLICY WITHOUT A PATH
FORWARD DOES NOTHING TO KEEP
AMERICA SAFE, SUPPORT OUR BORDER
PATROL AGENTS, PROTECT ASYLUM
SEEKERS OR BRING ABOUT THE
COMPREHENSIVE FIX OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM NEEDS.
AND HE'S FAR FROM ALONE.
SO WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE PEOPLE
WHO SAY WE'RE JUST NOT READY FOR
THIS?
>> WELL, ALISYN, GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
THE FIRST THING I WOULD SAY IS
THAT TITLE 42 IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
LAW.
IT WAS USED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO CIRCUMVENT
ACTUAL IMMIGRATION LAW, AND THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAD A
STRATEGY OF ENDING ALL THE LEGAL
PATHWAYS THAT WE HAD INTO THE
COUNTRY, EVEN THOUGH WE DIDN'T
HAVE SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF THOSE.
OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM HAS BEEN
BROKEN FOR A LONG TIME, SO WE
SHOULD BE CLEAR THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION USED TITLE 42 IN
WAYS IT NEVER SHOULD HAVE, BUT
ON TOP OF THAT, TITLE 42 HAS
DONE NOTHING TO SUPPORT ORDERLY
PROCESSES AT THE BORDER.
IN FACT, IT'S DONE THE OPPOSITE.
IT'S THROWN A LOT OF CHAOS IN
BECAUSE ASYLUM SEEKERS HAVE NO
LEGAL WAY TO ENTER THE COUNTRY,
AND SO THIS IS IMMIGRATION LAW
SHOULD BE -- YOU KNOW, WE SHOULD
RESPECT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
BOTH IN DOMESTIC LAW AND
INTERNATIONAL LAW THE RIGHT FOR
ASYLUM SEEKERS TO SEEK ASYLUM,
AND IF WE WANT TO FOCUS ON
FIXING THE IMMIGRATION SYSTEM,
WE SHOULD PASS THE KIND OF
LAWFUL PATHWAYS IN IMMIGRATION
REFORMS THAT WE NEED TO DO, BUT
REPUBLICANS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
WILLING TO DO THAT BECAUSE WE
HAVE CONTINUED TO USE IMMIGRANTS
AS A WEDGE ISSUE AND A POLITICAL
FOOTBALL AND IT'S DISGUSTING,
THEY SHOULD ACTUALLY STEP UP AND
HELP US TO PASS THOSE REFORMS.
>> AS YOU KNOW, EVERY
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
BEDEVILLED BY THE IMMIGRATION,
SOME SORT OF COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION PLANS FOR DECADES.
I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT
THE ORIGINS, WHICH MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN IN THE PUREST OF MOTIVES
BUT PRACTICALLY SPEAKING DO YOU
THINK THE BORDER CAN HANDLE
18,000 BORDER CROSSERS A DAY?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN, ALISYN.
THOSE NUMBERS INCLUDE REPEAT
BORDER CROSSINGS, AND PART OF
THE REASON IS BECAUSE ALL TITLE
42 DID IS EXPEL PEOPLE ACROSS
THE BORDER.
IT DIDN'T ACTUALLY PROCESS THEM,
AND SO YOU HAVE MULTIPLE PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO CROSS OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
SO THOSE NUMBERS ARE WAY
INFLATED, NUMBER ONE.
AND NUMBER TWO, YES, I ACTUALLY
THINK THAT THE NUMBERS WOULD GO
DOWN EVENTUALLY.
MAYBE NOT IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE
THERE'S SUCH A BUILD UP OF
PEOPLE AT THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
BORDER, BUT IF WE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT ORDERLY WAYS, AND WE
ALLOW PEOPLE TO EVEN APPLY IN
THEIR HOME COUNTRIES INSTEAD OF
COMING TO THE BORDER, ALL THINGS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THREW
OUT, THEN THAT'S HOW WE'RE GOING
TO ACTUALLY SEE THAT SITUATION
IMPROVE.
AND LET'S JUST BE CLEAR, WE'RE
ALL PUSHING FOR UKRAINIAN
REFUGEES TO BE ALLOWED ENTRY
INTO THE COUNTRY.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT FOR
HAITIANS AND OTHER LATIN
AMERICAN COUNTRIES, ASYLUM
SEEKERS COMING TO THE BORDER AS
WELL.
THIS IS A VERY DISCRIMINATORY
WAY TO GO ABOUT THE PROCESS AND
A DISORDERLY ONE THANKS TO THE
ILLEGAL IMPLEMENTATION OF TITLE
42.
>> LET'S MOVE ON TO STUDENT DEBT
AND FORGIVENESS OF STUDENT DEBT,
AND I KNOW THAT YOU THINK THAT
STUDENT DEBT SHOULD BE FORGIVEN.
I THINK $50,000 WORTH OF IT.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THAT.
CERTAINLY I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPULSE FOR STUDENTS THAT WOULD
BE WONDERFUL, AND LIFE CHANGING
BUT FOR OTHER AMERICANS, THERE
COULD BE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES, FOR INSTANCE, A
REPORT FROM THE COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE FEDERAL BUDGET
ESTIMATED THAT CANCELLING ALL
$1.6 TRILLION IN FEDERAL STUDENT
LOAN DEBT WOULD INCREASE
INFLATION BY .1 TO .5 PERCENTAGE
OVER THE NEXT 12 MONTHS, AND OF
COURSE THAT IS -- THIS IS NO
TIME THAT ANYBODY WANTS TO HEAR
ABOUT INFLATION BEING INCREASED.
>> WELL, ALISYN, FIRST OF ALL, I
WISH WE WERE GOING TO CANCEL ALL
THE STUDENT DEBT, BUT PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS BEEN CLEAR THAT THAT
IS NOT WHAT HE'S GOING TO DO.
BUT I WILL JUST SAY, THAT IF IT
WAS 50,000, THAT SAME REPORT
SAID THE IMPACT WOULD BE
NEGLIGIBLE ON INFLATION FOR SUCH
A SMALL AMOUNT, BUT ALSO ON TOP
OF THAT, LET'S BE CLEAR WHY THE
REPUBLICANS ARE ATTACKING THIS
POLICY.
IT'S BECAUSE IT'S INCREDIBLY
POPULAR ACROSS REPUBLICANS,
INDEPENDENTS, AND DEMOCRATS,
WHY, BECAUSE 99% OF THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE STUDENT DEBT, THAT 45
MILLION BORROWERS THAT HAVE
STUDENT DEBT ARE PEOPLE WHO DID
NOT GO TO IVY LEAGUE SCHOOLS.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING UNDER THE
CRUSHING BURDEN OF STUDENT DEBT.
40% OF THEM ALMOST HAVE NEVER
EVEN GOTTEN A COLLEGE DEGREE, SO
THIS IS HELPING REGULAR FOLKS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, AND IT'S NOT
JUST YOUNG PEOPLE, ALISYN, THE
FASTEST GROWING DEMOGRAPHIC WITH
PEOPLE WITH STUDENT LOANS NOW IS
SENIORS, PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING
ON FIXED INCOMES BUT EITHER ARE
STILL PAYING OFF THEIR STUDENT
DEBT OR ARE PAYING OFF THE DEBT
OF THEIR KIDS OR GRAND KIDS SO
THIS AFFECTS A WIDE GROUP OF
PEOPLE, AND IT WILL HELP LOWER
COSTS IN THIS INFLATIONARY TIME.
AND REALLY BRING RELIEF TO
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> ONE OTHER ARGUMENT AGAINST IT
IS THAT IT DOESN'T GET TO THE
ROOT PROBLEM AND THAT IS THE
SKYROCKETING COSTS OF TUITION.
I MEAN, THEY'VE JUST, YOU KNOW,
GONE UP EXPONENTIALLY,
INEXPLICABLY.
THE AVERAGE TUITION AND FEES AT
PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES HAVE JUMPED
144% IN THE PAST TEN YEARS.
OUT OF STATE HAS RISEN 171%,
IN-STATE TUITION AT PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES HAS GROWN 211%.
AND SO IT JUST DOESN'T -- IN
OTHER WORDS, YOU CAN FORGIVE THE
CURRENT DEBT BUT THEN WE'RE JUST
IN THIS VICIOUS CYCLE OF
ACCRUING MORE DEBT.
>> WELL, YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT'S A TWO-PART PROCESS.
WE GOT TO FORGIVE THE EXISTING
DEBT WHERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ACTUALLY PROFITING
ON THE INTEREST THAT PEOPLE ARE
PAYING JUST TO GET AN EDUCATION,
WHICH IS SOMETHING WE TELL
PEOPLE TO DO BECAUSE IT HELPS
OUR ECONOMY, BUT ON TOP OF THAT,
YOU'RE RIGHT, THAT'S WHY I HAVE
A COLLEGE FOR ALL BILL.
I'VE GOT A PLAN FOR THAT AS WELL
TO MAKE TUITION FREE FOR
FAMILIES EARNING UP TO 125,000.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
DISINVESTED OVER THE LAST DECADE
IN EDUCATION.
THAT'S A BIG REASON WHY TUITION
HAS INCREASED SO MUCH.
AND WE HAVE TO GET THAT UNDER
CONTROL.
AND WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
INVESTING IN PEOPLE'S EDUCATION
IS A BOON FOR OUR ECONOMY,
ALISYN.
IT HELPS US IN THE LONG RUN AND
THE SHORT RUN AND THE MEDI